we have a major Thor love and thunder
plot leak today that involves the one
and only Loki
god of mischief himself how's it going
everybody it's Warren and Thor love and
thunder is one of the most anticipated
films of phase 4 especially with the
reveal at San Diego comic-con that Jane
Foster is going to be returning and is
going to be playing a female version of
Thor and will lift mule near but with
mule near being destroyed in the main
MCU timeline and Captain America taken
the past mule near back to its original
time the question that everybody has
been asking is how exactly is Jane
Foster going to wield Mjolnir if there
is not a mule near in the current MCU
timeline well luckily for us thanks to a
current plot league for Thor love and
thunder we have learned how and it's all
thanks to Loki I'll break down the full
plot leak in this video but quick
reminder if you'd like a chance to win
an Xbox one or ps4 be sure to subscribe
to my channel like the video and comment
below with your favorite superhero or
villain to enter my giveaway I'll be
picking a winner at 500,000 subscribers
so thanks to this new plot league we
have learned that the Loki series is
going to connect directly with Thor love
and thunder which makes perfect sense
Kevin Feige has already explained that
the Disney Plus Marvel shows are going
to directly tie into the MCU so any
events that happen in these Disney Plus
shows happen in the MCU and affect the
movies and we have recently learned that
the Loki series is going to take place
right after Loki escapes with the
tesseract in 2012 when the Avengers went
back in time and Avengers endgame
according to this plot leaked Loki will
somehow manage to make his way back to
the main MCU timeline this is really no
surprise for the god of mischief this is
Loki that we're talking about here
he's extremely smart and it would make
sense that he figured out that the
Avengers went back in time and would
somehow figure out how to get to the
main timeline and according to this plot
leaked when he makes his way back to the
main timeline he's going to bring with
him mule near so this makes sense as to
how Mueller makes its way back to the
main timeline and how mule near is there
for Jane Foster to wield Loki bringing
mule near back to the main MCU timeline
answers a lot of questions but it brings
with it one really big question how
exactly can Loki lift mule near as we
all know mule near has a worthiness
charm on it so is Loki worthy enough to
lift Munir well considering the fact
that
loci were dealing with is the 2012 Loki
he's probably not worthy enough to lift
Mele near after all the 2012 Loki just
helped Thanos and tried to take over the
earth with the G tari
however Loki has lifted mule near in the
comics so Loki lifting Mjolnir means one
of two things one is that in some
alternate reality that he grabs this
mule near from there is no worthiness
enchantment placed on this mule near
that would be pretty easy because he
could just pick it up but what will most
likely see is some major character
development for Loki in the Disney Plus
series that will eventually lead to him
being worthy enough to lift mule near
this will make it to where Loki can
bring mule near back to the current MCU
timeline which is what the plot League
says will happen and this will also make
it to where Loki can appear in Thor love
and thunder and future MCU movies a lot
of fans were pretty upset with how Loki
died very early on in Avengers infinity
war Loki's a fan favorite and fans were
sad that we weren't going to see him in
any future MCU movies anymore but thanks
to the Loki Disney Plus show and this
plot leaked we know that Loki is going
to be returning to the MCU and the main
MCU timeline so Loki will be appearing
in future MCU movies and shows let me
know how excited you are about this and
let me know if you think that the 2012
Loki is going to be worthy enough to
lift muni r let me know in the comments
down below also don't forget to comment
with your favorite superhero or villain
like this video and subscribe to my
channel so you can enter my giveaway and
stay up to date on everything relating
to the MCU don't forget to follow me on
Twitter and Instagram and as always
thank you all so much for watching woof
woof